yeah dude steve was such a sweetheart
when uh when we were filming he said hey
man like
is it is it okay that uh that i drink a
beer
it said [ __ ] come on dude you know
like uh of course and it was so polite
of him to ask
but i don't think that they were filming
at the point when he asked that
it was breakfast yeah it's just great
yeah but you know i i didn't want to
just you know drink beer and you know
like
it'd be like me just busting it back
busting out an eight ball and snorting a
rail
that's great yeah hey excuse me while i
get my buzz on
[Laughter]
that's funny the way i view it um it's
just like uh
i mean what i don't like is when people
smoke pot because
like number one i [ __ ] love it
i love the way it smells i miss smoking
it i wish i could smoke it and i can't
and uh and and when i'm smelling it it's
just this feeling that i'm breathing it
in like it's like okay now
you're now your pot is entering my body
because i'm [ __ ] breathing it in and
i can't be doing that you know
but i'm you know your your beer is not
entering my body i don't
[ __ ] care with you
one of the things about beer is i mean
like my beer is made out of three
different hops
and just the smell of the hops when you
go into like a brewery that has a hop
room and you can stick your head in one
of those beds it just smells
so [ __ ] good and it almost smells
like like i think
i'm not a i don't smoke pot you know
it's just not my thing
but i love the smell of it before so
before someone lights it up it smells
wonderful yeah same thing with the hop
so and you know you get to formulate
that and turn it into a liquid so it's
fun for me to drink
but yeah to your point man when you
start smoking that [ __ ] you get the
second hand and it's
if you're trying to go straight edge no
can do
he says i don't i don't smoke pot it's
not my thing
but i love coke
for me that was years ago oh man that's
that's amazing
i was just i was just making a joke but
um
yeah dude